Claudia: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between McDonald's in the US and Italy.
This is "Food Wars."
Drinks at McDonald's in
Italy come in three sizes,
250 milliliters,
400 milliliters,
and 500 milliliters.
We're now going to measure
a 500-ml Coke to see if that's true.
Oh, oh.
I think we're surpassing that.
It's just right below the 600 mark,
but almost there.
So quite generous.
Drinks in the US also come in four sizes.
The extra small, which is 355 milliliters,
or 12 fluid ounces.
The small, 474 milliliters,
or 16 fluid ounces.
And the medium, 621
milliliters, or 21 fluid ounces.
And the large, 946 milliliters,
or 32 fluid ounces.
Since we were the ones that
filled this up at the restaurant
and I don't think we got it all full up,
I'm going to go ahead and fill this
what I think is reasonable.
I can't do to the top
because the cap is recessed.
OK. 32? Surely you jest.
But there's the 32 line. Not even close.
It's closer to 24 than it is 32.
So, fries in Italy come in three sizes.
The regular, which is
technically the small,
medium, and large.
Here in America, our
fries come in four sizes.
The kids, which comes in the Happy Meal.
Look at this little guy.
Little guy!
The small, the medium, and the large.
All the "Food Wars" heads watching
know that in the China episode,
our large McDonald's fry was 175 grams.
In the Japan episode,
our large McDonald's fry was 190 grams.
So clearly there's some
difference in grammage
depending on, I don't know,
the McDonald's we go to,
the scooper, who knows?
So we're going to weigh
our large right now.
Ready? Fantastic.
Eh, let's go 185.
Not a bad scoop. We got
a good scooper this time.
Seems pretty small, actually.
What about McNuggets?
In Italy you can get a bag of four,
a box of six pieces,
nine pieces, and 20 pieces.
Claudia, in the US,
our McNuggets are
available in these sizes:
the four-piece, the
six-piece, 10-piece, 20-piece,
which you also have, but we go
up one more here in America.
Our largest size, the 40-piece.
Now, if my calculations are correct,
this is double your largest size.
The iconic Big Mac.
Both countries have it,
but we're going to compare
ours to Italy's by weighing it.
226 grams for a US Big Mac.
And here is an Italian Big Mac,
or Il Big Mac, as is written here,
and we're going to weigh it now.
209 grams.
Here are all the items on
the McDonald's Italy menu
that you won't find in the US.
And here are all the McDonald's
menu items from the US
you won't find in Italy.
Get a good look, Claudia.
Let's start from the burgers.
We have a bunch of Italian burgers
that you won't get in the US.
The first one we got here
is a chicken Big Mac.
Oh, right. Just destroyed chicken Big Mac.
Has that been inverted?
Is that supposed to look like this?
The cheese helps a little
bit. Sauce as well.
Moving on, we have a bacon Big Mac.
Yeah, there's two strips of bacon,
but they're not quite
big, so it does look like
maybe it's just one
that's been cut in half.
We got a crispy McBacon,
which is like cheeseburger,
double patty, and some bacon
again, a bit on the side.
It's funny actually because growing up,
I thought that the crispy McBacon
was the iconic McDonald's item,
and it's weird that it is
actually an Italian exclusive.
Here are all the burgers in the US
that you can't get in Italy.
Starting down here, the
Quarter Pounder with cheese.
It really is just a cheeseburger
that is a quarter pound of meat.
It's a great go-to burger.
Meat, cheese, onions,
pickles, ketchup, and mustard.
And if you want more meat,
you can get the double Quarter Pounder.
Correct. Not the half pounder,
the double Quarter Pounder with cheese.
Two patties, more meat, more cheese.
Fantastic sandwich.
And then we've got the first one
of the My Selection range,
which is a range that was
designed with Joe Bastianich.
He's an American TV personality and chef.
This one is speck and Asiago,
so yeah, very traditional.
Speck is a type of cured
meat. It's like a smoked ham.
Yeah, it's a smoked ham
from the north of Italy.
It's actually very, very nice,
just very salty with that smoky flavor.
It's one of my favorites.
And then we have Asiago,
which is a cheese made
pretty much in the same area.
There's also mayo and zucchini in there.
A bit dry, I think.
You do taste the cold cut, the speck.
Just brings that saltiness, smokiness.
Very nice, and the cheese
also is quite good.
Yeah, actually I don't
know if you've noticed,
but it is much bigger than the others.
You can even take, like, bacon Big Mac.
Even though it's supposed
to have two patties,
it is much bigger.
And then we have another
My Selection burger.
This one is called My BBQ.
This one has got barbecue sauce,
yes, I can see it,
Gouda cheese, and bacon,
and it's all topped off
with some balsamic vinegar.
It does still have the
same sort of fancy patty
that we had before.
Right, and after these very
nice and fancy burgers,
we have a gluten-free burger.
Oh. [record scratching]
Wait, why does it come in a bag?
Ooh. Yeah. Very -- ooh.
Yeah, not excited about this.
Just, I don't like the bread.
I'm sure you can find
better gluten-free bread.
There are so many around.
And if you want vegetables on your burger
for some strange reason,
you can get the Quarter
Pounder with cheese deluxe,
with lettuce and tomato and mayo.
Oh, did you see that squirt coming out?
Hit, like, a pocket of
mayonnaise on that one.
That's kind of weird.
It tastes great.
And if you just want to
go all in on the meat,
you can get a double
Quarter Pounder with bacon.
Look at this.
Right?
It's really good. Enough said.
And, surprise, another thing on our menu
you guys don't have: the McDouble.
McDonald's has a double cheeseburger,
which is double the
meat, double the cheese,
but also there's a McDouble on the menu.
What's the difference, you ask?
Well, McDouble only has
one slice of cheese.
As you can see from here, on top,
you got ketchup, mustard,
and pickles, no cheese.
The cheese is in between here.
I get it. Times are tough in this economy,
but get the extra slice
of cheese, guys. Come on.
I mean, we're not robots here.
We gotta have some pleasure in our lives,
and I think you should get
that extra slice of cheese.
Absorb the cost of it.
It's perfectly fine.
You're doing great. Come on!
Next one is another one
of those My Selection.
It's a chicken, avocado, and bacon burger.
Hm, it's got a different bun, this one.
Ooh, fancy.
All right, yeah, avocado is there.
There's, like, cabbage.
Mm, bit less excited about that.
And this one has
caciocavallo Silano cheese.
I don't know. We can call this --
you know sauce talk. The cheese talk.
Caciocavallo comes from the
same family of mozzarella.
They're called pasta filata cheeses,
and it's just basically the
way that you make cheese,
when you split the milk
into curds and whey.
It's made in a different way.
And you could say that caciocavallo
is like an aged mozzarella.
So it's a very versatile cheese
that I think is not
very well known abroad.
So, yeah, thank you, McDonald's,
for making that a thing
on your menu so everybody
can know about it.
So, here's the cheese that we
were talking about. [laughs]
It's just always a shame.
It's been put there with,
like, avocado and this cabbage.
Next one, we've got
double chicken barbecue.
After seeing all these big
ones, they do look quite small.
And then we have a chicken burger.
This one is different from a McChicken
because it has Caesar
sauce and no lettuce.
I think this is glue.
It looks like -- there is a type of glue
that looks exactly like that.
We also thought it'd be
fun to compare Happy Meals.
Here's the US one.
Open up this box, take a look around.
I'm pretty sure this is Pokémon.
This one comes with kid fries,
nuggets, which, we got a six-piece,
and this is their Pokémon toy.
So, they get the six-piece.
It's funny, like, a six-piece still seems
kind of like a lot for a kid.
Pokémon-themed toys
coming at you these days.
What is this?
OK, so we got Pikachu.
Does this have any value?
Because there's rare ones.
There's ones that have
a lot of value to them.
But not the ones at McDonald's, right?
Cyclizar? Any value?
We got Tandemaus.
Yeah.
And, of course, Sandaconda.
I'll go look on eBay after this
and see if these are worth anything.
Culturally, I have no idea what this is.
I don't know what -- this is a thing?
No, I have no idea who.
I don't remember any of those names.
Charlizard?
Cylizard?
Is this Cylizard?
Charmagarg.
OK.
In a Happy Meal in Italy,
you can find four items.
Obviously there is a drink,
then there is a main course
that could be either
nuggets [or] a hamburger.
And exclusive to Italy is a chicken burger
and a McToast, which is what we got today.
We're going to see that in a moment.
Then there is a side.
It can either be fries or baby carrots.
And a dessert.
This can be either fresh fruit, Actimel,
which is technically a drink
but it's a dessert here,
and Parmesan.
Here's our McToast. Nice.
The surprise of the day.
Yeah, they're just doing some
Hot Wheels collaboration.
So let's have a look at what is it.
I don't know, do you think
I can find a Vespa in here?
Oh, cute little skateboard,
pink one.
Nyoom.
We also have one exclusive
wrap option here in Italy.
It's a McWrap with crisp chicken breast
and Parmesan, or Parmigiano-Reggiano.
It's made in collaboration
with Giallozafferano,
which is the No. 1
recipe website in Italy.
To be honest, I think
they could have come up
with a better recipe, maybe, for the wrap.
The wrap does look very
sad, just the actual bread.
Chicken looks OK.
Italy clearly has plenty of exclusive
chicken-sandwich options, but
we have a few of our own here,
namely the McCrispy and the spicy McCrispy
and a deluxe version of each sandwich.
Let's take a look.
It looks closer to a chicken sandwich
you would find at a Chick-fil-A,
and then now Burger King has
the chicken king, I think?
McDonald's did all the
research that they do
to release this, the McCrispy sandwich.
Now, as you can tell,
it's just pickles on here.
A crispier, more natural-looking
piece of fried chicken,
and no sauce. Does it
always have no sauce?
I don't like that. I don't like
a place that gives you food
and, like, assembly requirements.
For the most part, I
should get the sandwich
the way it's supposed to be.
So this put your own sauce in it,
it's like, no, you put it on.
Here's the deluxe of it.
Yay, it has mayo. Whoa.
This to me is like,
yeah, do this every time.
This should just be the
sandwich. I don't ...
If you're like me and
you want to spice it up,
ah,
they have the spicy -- oh, come on.
There's spicy sauce on here somewhere.
Then, of course, they
got the spicy deluxe,
which of course has spicy sauce
and all those veggies in there.
So, yeah. McDonald's, still a contender
in the chicken-sandwich game, I feel.
Now we're on to the exclusive
sides here in Italy.
The first one that we got is cheesy fries.
The same fry, just with a
bit more bacon we got here.
Yeah, cheddar and bacon.
This is, like, I don't know,
a very sad Italian take on poutine.
On the menu next for sides,
we've got panzerotti.
So, actually very excited
about these because,
ooh,
panzerotti are from my hometown,
Bari, in the south of Italy.
The main difference is
that usually panzerotti,
the traditional ones, they are this big.
They're usually pretty wide.
It's, like, a main meal.
Panzerotti normally, they
have, tomatoes and mozzarella
is the most common filling,
but in Bari, again,
where they are from, you can
get them with ground beef,
mozzarella, and cooked ham.
These are actually my favorites.
I used to go and get them after school.
That's just, they are the perfect snack.
Quite good, actually.
Filling is OK, but I
think a real panzerotto,
when you bite into it,
basically all the filling
should almost come out.
It should, like, pop.
Like, the first reaction
when you eat a panzerotti,
this is like,
and then you sort of put your hand here
and just avoid a complete mess.
This brings us to the next snack,
which is Parmigiano-Reggiano, or Parmesan.
This is one of the most
counterfeit cheeses
in the world, so.
In Italy but also in Europe,
because of this whole protection thing,
anything that's called even
Parmesan, not the real name,
Parmigiano-Reggiano, is
in fact the real thing,
so at least we are safe on that side.
Having said that, I think
most of the Parmesan,
Parmigiano that you will
find around in supermarkets,
it's been aged for the bare minimum,
which is 12 months.
So it is good, it is the real thing,
but if you can choose,
just have something that's
been aged for a bit longer.
I think in Italy we do eat a lot of cheese
as a snack as it is, and I
do have definitely memories
of me coming back from school
and then just in the afternoon grabbing
some cheese off the fridge
and having a couple of slices
or even more than that.
I think my mom still does that,
so, sorry for exposing you, Mom.
Love it.
Over here we got another exclusive.
There are actually three
salads on the menu.
One is just a plain salad,
one is a salad with tomatoes,
and then we got one with crispy
chicken breast and Parmesan.
We could also select a dressing,
and we added olive oil.
You could also get a tiny
bottle of balsamic vinegar
or just vinegar.
We actually have no
exclusive sides in the US.
Every side option on our menu
can also be found in Italy.
I will say, though, I love that they have
a stick of cheese as a side,
kind of like a palate cleanser.
I would love that.
I would love to snack on cheese.
I love snacking on cheese.
We should have more cheese,
is what I'm trying to say.
We can bring it back with the sauces.
It's time for sauce talk, Italy edition.
La la la sauce talk!
That had to offend somebody.
Sauce talk.
We have several exclusive sauces
here in the United States,
including spicy Buffalo,
and then we have ranch, honey
mustard, sweet 'n' sour.
Now, I have two because one
is from the movie "Loki," apparently.
And of course you just get honey.
Of all these, I'd probably
go sweet 'n' sour,
but barbecue, which they
do have, is my favorite.
We have one exclusive sauce in Italy,
which is spicy mustard sauce.
Yeah.
Yeah, it is a bit spicy.
Not so much, though.
Doesn't numb your tongue.
I think actually it has a sweet
aftertaste for some reason.
For the early risers,
there are plenty of
exclusive breakfast items
at the US McDonald's,
and they're all savory.
Now, first thing I'm going to
talk about are the biscuits.
I'm not the person to
describe American biscuits
to the rest of the world.
They should have hired a poet.
This is the bacon, egg,
and cheese biscuit,
but you can get a biscuit version
of any meat or cheese
combination that you want.
In the middle here, though,
Italy, Claudia, everyone,
look at what I'm about to show you.
You know what pancakes are.
You know what syrup is.
You obviously know what
breakfast sandwiches are.
This right here is a McGriddle,
and they replaced the buns with this.
These bun pancakes.
This is a pancake, Italy. A pancake.
These, here. And they somehow
injected syrup in them,
so it's not like syrup like a sauce,
it's just, like, already syrup somehow,
and it is savory and
sweet at the same time.
It is so delicious.
It's a McGriddle. It's
fantastic. I love these.
This is a bacon, egg,
and cheese McGriddle,
but once again, you can get
it in any various sausage,
egg, and/or cheese
combination that you want.
McGriddles. Check 'em out.
I am the McGriddle No. 1 fan over here.
And the OG breakfast sandwich,
this is the egg McMuffin.
They got the Big Breakfast
with or without hotcakes.
I went with hotcakes.
You got eggs, bacon,
pancakes, English muffin,
this thing's fantastic.
And if you want to just
get hotcakes and sausage,
you can also do that.
And each order of pancakes
comes with our hotcakes syrup.
I think an unsung hero of the
McDonald's breakfast menu,
been a fan of this for years,
it is the sausage breakfast burrito.
Now, let's be honest.
Italy, in case you're wondering,
this in no way represents
an actual burrito.
I want to make that perfectly clear.
I would not put this in the same category
as any sort of burrito,
breakfast or otherwise,
but it's its own thing, and
I think it is fantastic.
It is in a flour tortilla.
Scrambled eggs, sausage, yes, I know,
peppers, cheese, and the secret weapon
is this, their Mexican-style salsa.
Again, there is nothing
authentically Mexican about this,
but it tastes great.
This was a go-to for years.
I could put away about four of these.
McDonald's also does offer oatmeal,
specifically fruit and maple oatmeal.
Moving on.
The Italian McDonald's
also sells breakfast items.
We've got ... [laughs]
That's super sad.
We got scrambled eggs with
bacon and a muffin and bread,
which does look more like a muffin.
And then we have a McMuffin
with bacon and egg.
Yeah, Italians don't really
have savory breakfast.
It's definitely a habit.
Like, you just associate
breakfast with sweet items.
All right, US also has their
own exclusive McCafé items.
Where'd they go?
The McDonald'ses near our studio
did not have the McCafé food items.
McDonald's in Italy has
really made an effort
with the McCafé menu items,
and there are really a lot
of items on the menu here.
So let's start from the croissants.
We've got quite a few on the menu.
I think this one here,
because you can see a little bit of brown,
this is the cocoa one with sourdough.
Pretty safe to eat.
This is the plain one.
Does look more like a
French-style croissant.
Nice layers in there as well, some air.
Over here, it's quite hard to tell,
but there is a subtle,
subtle layer of jam.
This is berries and cereal.
So, the dough, it's a little bit stiffer,
and, yeah, does smell a little bit
more like cereals.
Same amount of jam as in the others.
Not very generous, actually.
I think this one is the
last one that we got,
so it's the custard.
This looks like we have
a bit more in there.
Obviously, it's hard to tell
because the custard is the
same color as the dough,
has kind of turned the dough yellow.
Nice. Lots of lemon in there.
Another pastry option that you can get
is this cream braid.
This is quite a typical
thing as well in Italy.
Like, you do get these kind of pastries.
You can get them also savory
in different regions of Italy.
Let's see if they were
generous with the cream here.
Mm, yeah, I'll say so.
I prefer this cream.
In Italy, you can also get some cakes.
We have tiramisu, which is,
yeah, traditional Italian thing,
but not a breakfast item.
Like, I wouldn't really have
breakfast with tiramisu.
I know you guys want to hear
the opinion of an Italian,
so we're going to try this
tiramisu and see if it's proper.
Yes, quite good, actually.
We do have other cakes as well.
We have this one, which is
torta della nonna in Italian,
and that literally translates to
"grandma's cake" in English.
This one has lemon custard and pine nuts.
I think it's a bit of a joke
that this is actually
called grandma's cake
just because every Italian grandma
that's good in the kitchen
will be able to make something,
like, 100 times better than this.
We've got a strawberry cheesecake.
Let's move on to this
three-layer chocolate cake.
It's an absolute beast.
It's a bit too much.
I wouldn't have this for breakfast.
And then we have a few more items here
at the McCafé in Italy.
We have a marshmallow doughnut,
which looks like the most artificial thing
I've ever seen.
Then we've got a Nutella muffin.
It is true that Italians love Nutella,
and they eat it all the time.
Again, when I was a child,
my parents used to hide it.
Mm, sad. [laughs]
And the last item that
we've got is macarons.
We have chocolate macarons,
raspberry macarons,
and pistachios macarons,
or pistacchio, as we do say here.
Oh, the inside is, like,
dangerously green.
They don't taste so much
like pistachio, to be honest.
Desserts, McDonald's US,
we have these exclusives.
Starting down here, the baked apple pie.
The day they stopped frying these
is the day I stopped eating them.
Now they're pulling this with, like,
trying to make it look like
it's a homemade pastry.
It's not. This was just spit out
of an AI oven machine.
Blip, blip, blip. One a second. No human.
I'm the first human hand to touch this.
Also chocolate chip cookies.
They come in orders of
one, three, the trilogy,
or a tote of 13.
One good thing about the
McDonald's we went to today
is the McFlurry machine
was totally working,
and I got this one, the M&M's McFlurry.
We use the mini M&M's,
which are better than regular M&M's,
I don't know why, they just are.
Sundaes, sundaes, sundaes.
Maybe my favorite as a
kid, the caramel sundae.
Mm. Ooh, that's my childhood right there.
And you can get a fudge one as well.
For Italian exclusive desserts,
we have a pistachios McFlurry,
then a Baci Perugina McFlurry.
Baci Perugina are very popular chocolates.
They are made in Perugia, which
is in the center of Italy,
a town in the center.
And here we have a coffee sundae.
It's quite nice that they
actually gave us the espresso
so that we can make our own.
A bit like an affogato, in a way.
The other sundaes are caramel, berries,
another Baci Perugina again,
and the fior di latte,
which is basically the
Italian version of vanilla.
Ooh.
Nice, yeah.
Now on to the cold drink
options, starting down here,
all the soda options
you get here in the US.
Of course, we have way more than Italy.
Starting with Dr Pepper.
Oh, OK there.
So fantastic.
Diet Coke. No.
Ugh.
This completely unnatural-looking thing
is Hi-C Orange Lavaburst.
It's not carbonated,
but it's also not juice.
I can't explain it. It's Hi-C.
You can also get a sweet tea
and an unsweetened iced tea at McDonald's.
What I did feel like getting was this,
the frozen Fanta blue raspberry.
Oh, God, it's so sweet and so syrupy.
Don't drink this, don't
give it to children,
don't have it ever.
They also have a Coke
version, frozen Coke.
Also don't bother.
Lemonade, though.
So, we found out that lemonade in America
is the least different
from lemonade in the UK.
Again, this is not carbonated,
it's not really juice,
it's something different.
I don't know what
lemonade is like in Italy.
Oh, man, it's so tart and so good.
On to coffee drinks,
or should I say cold coffee drinks,
from here to here.
I understand that's not a thing in Italy,
which I think is hilarious.
This giant glass right
here is iced coffee.
You can also get it caramel flavored
or French vanilla flavored.
I went with black, the
ace of spades right here.
Mm.
Oh, man, they do something
with their coffee there.
They do something where it
tastes like it's really roasted.
I mean, I'm sure it's not.
You can also get a iced latte.
This over here is a frappé.
You can get a mocha frappé
or a caramel frappé.
Basically if you're an adult
and you want a milkshake,
you get a frap.
You can also get smoothies at McDonald's.
We have a mango pineapple smoothie
and a strawberry banana smoothie.
In Italy, we have a few exclusive drinks.
Let's start with the cold options.
We have Lipton iced tea
both in lemon and peach.
Then we have some fruit juices.
We have pear,
ace, which is very popular here in Italy.
It should be very orange.
It's a mix of orange, carrots, and lemon.
Yeah, very orange.
And it's named ace, which is A-C-E,
after the three vitamins
that these fruits,
or vegetables, I guess,
these carrots, contains.
And then we got peach fruit juice.
And here are our McDonald's
hot coffee drinks.
"Coffee," right, Italy?
All right, we get it.
We went a little overboard
with our coffee drinks
here in America, and McDonald's,
of course, is no different.
You can get a caramel macchiato,
a caramel cappuccino.
Why are we doing so much
caramel stuff in America, right?
Ah, caramel latte.
You can also get it in vanilla.
Don't.
You can also get a mocha latte.
We have a premium roast coffee.
As I said before, I don't
know what they're doing
at McDonald's, but
I like the coffee.
But you can also get,
finally, a black hot tea.
What is this? The UK?
Ugh.
The hot drinks exclusive to Italy
are obviously the king
of hot drinks, espresso.
Then we've got a Moroccan coffee,
which is not Moroccan in the sense of
it's not Moroccan-style
coffee, but weirdly enough,
and to be honest, I never
really understood this,
it's named after a type
of Moroccan leather
that looks this color.
Honestly, it's like an
espresso with some milk.
And then we got ginseng
coffee and barley coffee,
which technically shouldn't
really be called coffee
because it contains no
coffee, it has just barley,
and this is like an alternative for people
that cannot drink coffee
and they still want to have something
like a little espresso after lunch.
Yeah, it smells very cereally.
I don't know. I'm not a big fan.
And then we got just a
standard latte macchiato.
This is the closest thing
you will get to a latte
that you will find here in Italy,
so it's just a lot of
milk with a bit of coffee
and some foam at the top.
In Italy, a Big Mac will cost
you 6 euros and 10 cents.
In dollars, that's about $6.76.
A Big Mac in the US will cost you $6.29.
That's a 3% price increase
from Italy to the US.
What if you turn that into a combo meal?
In Italy, a small Big Mac
meal with medium fries
and a medium drink will
cost you 8 euros 90,
and that's $9.86.
Does a combo meal make
a difference in the US?
A medium Big Mac combo meal over here
will cost you $11.42.
You can also save some
money if you buy in bulk.
Here in Italy, you can
get a two-person Mac menu,
which includes two Big Macs,
two large portions of fries,
two large Coca-Colas, six nuggets,
for 18 euros.
In the US, we only do Big Mac combo meals,
as mentioned before.
So in order to get the
same order in Italy,
you would have to order two Big Mac meals
plus six nuggets on the side.
It would cost around $36, which
in Italy is about 33 euros.
Price-wise, I think they
are definitely better value
than other fast-food chains.
Well, not to believe Five Guys,
I know that one has a reputation
for being quite expensive,
but I think the burger
is, like, half the price.
For the panzerotti, I think
that was more than 3 euros,
3 euros something, which, honestly,
for, like, three of those as a
side, it is a little bit sad.
But again, I grew up in
the town of panzerotti,
and I used to have, like,
a full one this size
for, like, 2 euros. That was 15 years ago,
so maybe now it would
translate into something
like maybe 5 or 6.
Once upon a time, McDonald's
was the cheaper option.
It was a lot of food
for not a lot of money.
As many people probably
pointed out on social media,
this food is no longer
inexpensive. It's not expensive.
Maybe because of the competition,
maybe because of inflation,
probably because of corporate greed,
McDonald's and most fast food, I find,
is not a good value anymore.
Let's compare some items to see
what the nutrition is of McDonald's food.
A sandwich that exists in both countries
and is theoretically
identical is the Big Mac.
In the US, a Big Mac
contains 590 calories,
34 grams of total fat, 46 grams of carbs,
and 9 grams of sugar.
How about an Italian Big Mac?
One of those here contains 509 calories.
Of these, there are 26 grams of total fat,
42 grams of carbs, of
which 9 grams are sugars,
and then there are 920
milligrams of sodium.
What if we made it a combo meal?
Starting with the fries,
a medium fry in the US
contains 320 calories,
15 grams of total fat,
43 grams of carbs, no sugar,
and 260 milligrams of sodium.
While a medium fries in
Italy contains 330 calories,
16 grams of total fat, 41 grams of carbs,
of which 0.4 grams are sugars,
and 212 milligrams of sodium.
And let's add the medium
Coke into the mix.
It contains 210 calories, no fat,
56 carbs, 56 of those are sugar,
and 55 milligrams of sodium.
That's funny there's salt in the soda.
We'll do the same here.
Here's what's inside a
medium Coke in Italy.
It's 168 calories,
zero grams of fat,
42 grams of carbs, 42 grams of sugar,
so it's all sugar,
and zero grams of sodium.
That leaves the total for
the Italian meal at this:
1,007 calories,
42 grams of fat,
125 grams of carbs,
51.4 grams of sugars,
and 1,132 milligrams of sodium.
While in the US, the total
ends up looking like this.
Let's talk about ingredients now.
McDonald's Italy shares a
lot of information, actually,
about its ingredients.
That's because the majority
of the items on the menu
are made with 100% Italian products.
The beef, like the one
that's used in the Big Mac,
is sourced from over
15,000 different farms
located in northern Italy
around the regions of
Lombardy, where we are now,
the capital of which is Milan,
and Piedmont.
There are apples from South Tyrol,
which is where speck is made,
just on the border with Austria.
And just to give some recognition
to the southern regions,
because I'm from there,
so no bias at all, we've got some apricots
from the Vesuvio National
Park, so in Campania,
and Sicilian oranges.
And when we talk about
DOP, this red label here,
it's what you are looking for.
It's a label that's used for
a lot of traditional products
around the EU, and that means
that they have to be made
following certain specific standards,
most of the time in a very artisanal way.
That also means that certain
products like Parmesan
cannot be made outside of a specific area.
That has to do with the climate.
So, for example, for cheese,
the main argument is that
it's a raw-milk cheese,
and in raw-milk cheeses, you
do taste what the cows eat.
So obviously, the grass
has a different taste
depending on where you are in the world.
But we do have some
American-sourced ingredients
for McDonald's.
The potatoes used for our
fries are grown in Washington
at 100 Circles Farm,
which is owned by Bill Gates, apparently.
They grow the potatoes in circles so big
you can see it from space.
The potatoes are then cut into
fries at 70 miles per hour,
which is faster than a cheetah.
That's the unit of measurement?
That not-so-secret ingredient
to McDonald's fries
is beef flavoring, which they've
been doing since the 1950s.
You want to see if there's
any differences in the US
and Italy's Big Mac?
These are all the ingredients
in a Big Mac in the US.
Altogether, that's 68 ingredients
that make up a Big Mac.
That's a lot.
28 of those ingredients are in the bun,
which is quite a lot for bread.
The Big Mac sauce also
has a lot of ingredients,
26 altogether, and it seems like we added
a lot of relish to ours, which
bulks out the ingredients.
In Italy, there are 54
ingredients in a Big Mac.
Here they are.
We only have 20 ingredients
in the bun, actually,
because we don't fortify the
flour like you do in the US.
Our Big Mac sauce has 15 ingredients,
which is still nine less
than the US Big Mac, Joe.
Most of the other ingredients are similar,
but we don't have as many colorings
or thickeners as you do in the US.
Some of the ingredients
listed in our US Big Mac sauce
caught our attention, so we
want to explain what they are.
First up, propylene glycol alginate
is derived from brown seaweed
and is a thickener used in foods
to give a smooth natural texture.
Next up we got hydrolyzed corn,
which is a plant protein
from corn or maize
and is used as a flavoring
for its umami taste.
Sodium citrate helps cheese to
melt without becoming greasy.
I did grow up with McDonald's.
I definitely celebrated a
couple birthdays over there.
I had my share of Happy Meals
with lots of little girly toys.
It is definitely considered healthier
than other fast-food chains
because it has been around
for quite some time,
but also, obviously,
because it has Italianized
a lot over the years,
incorporating things like Parmesan
or like traditional cheeses and cold cuts.
So just appealing a little bit more
to the taste of Italians.
I have been to stores
in the US and the UK,
and Italian McDonald's seem, I don't know,
a little bit fancier.
It's everywhere and made burgers and fries
and sodas to go the most
popular meal in the country,
and then how many places followed suit?
With Burger King and
Wendy's and all the like.
And now we got
chicken-sandwich-version ones,
we got fried chicken.
McDonald's McDonald's-ified
the entire country
and the world.
McDonald's is like Nike or Christianity.
It's everywhere!
The No. 1?
Yuelei: It's like the mascot of the show.
OK. And is it named Pokémon?
Yuelei: No! Pokémon is a
type. It's like the animal.
Oh.